variable body back baby welcome to
another another another another episode
of Tiger belly oh boy God well we got a
great show in store for you I'll tell
you that right now cha cha we got some
good ones man we've got so many people
regulars here in the room we've got
kalila kun we got Rudy big bad Rudy Rudy
Rudy we've got George and this terrible
[ __ ] shirt [ __ ] pink head of his I
love it do you not know how to say me
and Giuliana's last name kyun kill what
what is it long around the oh babe kyun
kyun get killed up alone I said that way
that's correct we kill book alone and
then we've got a couple of fine guests
coming up fine decent Americans they're
friends of mine
we did a movie together called the wrong
Missy I had one line I think that's what
I think that's what I was bummed about
it's the mood that's what it is what it
is is because I had one line in the
movie and then we're promoting it and I
just feel shameful that I had nothing to
do in it wait isn't that kind of wait so
I see they gave you one line in the
movie and then they're asking they're
asking you to promote it yeah I mean
that's essentially what it I feel I
think that I think that's where my
depression comes from I mean let me get
me wrong I'm grateful to be in it and
then it was really fascinating to work
with Spade and Adam Sandler and all
those guys but you know it's just uh
it's I think the least amount of things
I've had to do in a movie I think yeah
yeah in any movie so that's I want to
lift your mood but oh yeah but Colella
has to lift my mood right now so go
ahead I want to lift your mood with a
Filipino love song she's gonna fill
Peter loves on the video I want you to
look at me when I sing it to you you're
gonna have to be on screen so I have to
do like this okay you ready okay I hope
this is make him upset what if this
makes him much I'm already rageful now
okay
my closer you have right you have to
absorb my love when I sing it to you
okay
okay kahit nd Guapo
she called him handsome is that what it
is although she was saying that I was
like a piece of [ __ ] or whatever let's
start from the top
ready one two couple guide Nadi Maithili
no mustache I'm my boo saw your [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you Bobby what do you think that
all meant what puso that has to be good
honest that's right let's translate the
first sentence yeah I thought puso was a
good thing what do you think that means
hi he did the wig waka
I hate Hindi Guapo Guapo Guapo is a
handsome so it wopo you really want to
know what so you are very handsome no it
says even if you're not handsome indeed
not yet well you're saying that I'm not
in the second line switch success next
thing Sam laughing oh that dad joke
shook me babe so so what's the second
way you translate it the second line is
Chi hidden edema tulino kahit delete
that belly mo is that a little more the
mayor of some Filipino Ireland no it
means even if you're not smart
oh I'm not smart it's the [ __ ] song
you bring us a third line cloth what's
happening here I got a hand so I'm not
smart more it says this lightly then he
goes vested shame a puso me as long as
he has a good heart
he's the one I'm gonna choose
beautiful that I thought I didn't write
the lyrics guys I thought it meant my
feasto in your [ __ ] well that's a nice
song did you write that or is that an
old Filipino traditional song it's a
song from the 90s
oh so that's a Brit so you didn't write
it I didn't write it though
okay well that you know that folks that
feel good thank you so much baby and I
feel great I feel like it make you feel
worse it made me feel like I was just I
just got out of a pow2 I swear relief
there's relief there wait a second I
want you to sing me a Korean love song
oh no I'm gonna make it up I'm not gonna
hack it out no this is real I know it
yeah yeah I know
kyla translation araguaia
well he'll tell you yeah I said you're
very pretty good I said your [ __ ] is
hideous something okay yeah I said then
I said her face is strange
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] wall that's true do all
right so you're beautiful you want me
speaking in English yeah best in the
world
you're so beautiful to me your vagina is
pure he's like Jesus is mom's [ __ ] too
yeah Mary Mary oh but uh so I'm gonna
talk to you about Gilbert yeah what's up
I saw you playing war zone how did you
know that it's online everyone's talking
about the amazing play from the Lee
brothers so right so